have you ever proactively looked for a
partner and thinking a lot about finding
a partner no it's always kind of
stumbled upon me typically people who
are competent and looking for that same
thing in a partner they focus on
bettering themselves before they focus
on looking for another a human who's
like I really just want to be with
somebody I want to be with somebody I'm
ready how do I find my person get that
energy out of your life as both a woman
which I can speak more to and a man and
instead become somebody worth finding
and that's really hard to hear but when
you start working out which doesn't mean
you have to be perfectly fit but you
have more energy when you start pursuing
something that you're uniquely
interested in you're more interesting
and thus you will attract more
interesting people I think one of the
worst things we've ever done is allow
dating apps to enter into our dating
equation we have thought that it is a
numbers game of finding the right person
as opposed to becoming the right person
when you become the right person you
will attract people continuously no
matter what and I've seen this from both
myself and my friends who are varying
levels of attractive varying levels of
rich but working really hard on a few
things that make them very interesting